guns is a special case because it does
have very dire consequences for misuse
of other people's freedom so you know
the general libertarian perspective or
principle that you know I should be free
to to do what I want as long as I don't
restrict your freedoms from doing what
you want that is the freedom for me to
swing my arm ends at your nose
okay so guns are a special case I've
long been pretty much against gun
control that is people should choose to
do what they want I've since gone back
and forth on this mainly because the
rates of accidents and suicides and
homicides is so high when guns are
readily available it is a complex
statistical argument in both directions
more guns less guns more crime less
crime which way does it go which state
which county carrying concealed laws
this is one of the more complex social
science problems I've ever looked into
and and I have to say it isn't really
obvious other than if you look at states
like in your most European states that
either happen where no one has guns or
almost no one has guns they have nothing
like even remotely like the gun violence
we have so clearly if no-one had guns we
wouldn't have a gun problem that said
that's never going to happen in America
there are about 320 million guns on the
streets but the people's homes or
whatever we're never gonna take him back
no one's gonna go house to house you
know like Nazis breaking down the doors
and stealing people's guns that's never
gonna happen so and ok in fact the
Supreme Court's voted twice and oh six
and oh eight particularly the Heller
case handgun case in Washington DC it is
protected by the second event that snot
going to change anytime soon so let's
face up to that and see if we could do
something to just reduce the carnage you
know like why are people allowed to buy
ar-15s and ak-47 rifles what are those
for you know I I grew up hunting with
shotguns I had a 20 gauge and a 12-gauge
shotgun shotguns are used for shooting
birds out of this guy we're certain
rifles are good for deer hunting okay I
get all that and handguns for
self-defense okay
understand I'm not I'm not gonna have
one in my house too many risks there but
still if you want one okay but what's
the purpose of an ar-15 or ak-47 it was
designed to kill as many people as
possible in a short time as possible and
of course that's exactly what it's used
for target practice
I don't know maybe I guess some people
say they enjoy that I don't know but
they're I would say the risk is too high
of it being misused and as we've clearly
seen in recent terrorist attacks
anybody can get one they're not hard to
get and that's a problem